just cop this Cat Williams baby let's
get it and what did you get me Merry
Christmas she gave me ground beef when I
was like not give you ground beef she's
like it's good meat it's good meat oh my
God Christmas oh my God Mom it's a
matrix shirt this is the best present
ever you must have heard your sled
painter Clauses is that you those red
and white packages they are like the
shiny packages underneath the Christmas
tree they are the color of Santa Claus
they're common in Siberia they're eaten
constantly by Caribou Caribou are
reindeer you know what we did today we
went out and bought the tree buy a tree
oh we got a tree we got a tree last week
the price of these trees I haggled
bones Christmas tree